- [Kelly] You have a
new 16 month old, right?
A little baby?
- I do.
(Audience cheers)
- [Kelly] That's exciting,
What's one of your toughest
mom moments that you've had?
- Well, recently, very recently,
he's 16 months now and, you know,
it's like you learn what they understand
and what they don't,
what they're absorbing,
what they're not absorbing.
And he was eating dinner,
and my husband said something
that really annoyed me
as husbands do.
(audience laughs)
- I don't know what you're referring to.
- Yeah, and I like
kinda raised my voice at him,
I was probably like, "Ryan,
blah blah blah blah!"
And Baz, my son, he went:
"Momma,
no, no, no."
(audience giggles and coos)
- Oh!
- Like that.
And I was like
Like I,
like, my heart broke, 'cause I was like
"Oh! No!" I like--
- "'cause I'm a horrible human."
- No, well, yeah!
It was just like he was
putting me in my place,
I was kind of really proud
of him for doing that.
But, you know, it was like
"You're right. I'm sorry.
Mommy shouldn't raise her voice at daddy."
and I had to apologize to him.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, my poor children.
(Kelly chuckles)
(audience laughs)
You know, usually we don't argue really,
my husband and I, but like
we're both very passionate.
- Yes, very passionate.
- You're household is probably what,
you know, what you should do.
(both laugh)
And mine is like,
waaah!
- I am also very pa--
like, people call it screaming,
I just call it talking.
- Exactly!
- This is how I talk.
- That's what I say.
- I'm allowed to talk.
- I am too.